okay Conan what's really behind andy's
podium during your monologue you know I
have not actually seen what's behind
andy's podium but i see him moving
around a lot back there sometimes I hear
old classic movies and I hear him eating
something but other than that I can't I
can't honestly say what's back there
your name yamaraja Jimin Jimin is okay
you just hit a bunch of bunch of
consonants on the screen what type of
sandwich is your favorite oh man I love
a corned beef sandwich on an onion roll
that's my favorite sandwich of all
little Russian dressing that's good see
how many great t-shirts do you own how
many great a lot of great t-shirts that
go with great t-shirts because they
don't clash with anything I also have
embarrassing t-shirts from the pass Mork
& Mindy shirt stuff like that that I
don't wear Luka McNamee says Conan I'm a
history major in college what's your
favorite area my area of history I would
have to say early 20th century American
history fascinates me that I love that
Theodore Roosevelt gotta love that blue
moose party of course anything from the
sinking of the Titanic set oh please I
could go on and on a Conan are you still
in the office yes well I'm not in my
office I'm in the head writers office
Mike Sweeney I'm sitting at his desk and
he's got like a giant comical lighter
here some scripts which are not funny
for tomorrow
pictures of his children which I won't
show and he's a big fan of the Thor
movie so this is loci I think this is
Loki and he's holding a sex toy I think
like says you won't